optimal like this altitude I can run
flat out for a half-mile before my hands
start shaking and I ask you a personal
question now soon I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by audible which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is perhaps my favorite audio
book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing you will thank me
the graveyard book the second is
vagabonding by Rolf pots which had a
huge impact on my life and form the
basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash tim TI m and
you can choose one of those two books or
you can choose from more great options
than you can possibly imagine so that
could be a book that could be a magazine
that could be a newspaper it could be a
class it's that easy go to audible.com
forward slash Tim that's audible.com
forward slash Tim and grab a book
enjoy this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront com forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
put you in and if you just want to take
their advice run with it do it yourself
you can do that or as I would you can
set it and forget it and here's why the
value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
to deconstruct world-class performers
whether they're from the worlds of
sports investing acting military
anything and everything to help to tease
out the routines habits favorite books
etc that you can use this particular
episode is a repeat guest Tony Robbins
and 20 of I have gotten to know each
other over the last few years since I
first had him on the podcast an epic
two-parter which was very long and very
very good one of the most popular
episodes I've had of the podcast to date
Tony Robbins is the world's most famous
performance coach for those of you don't
know the name he's advised everyone from
Bill Clinton to Serena Williams from Leo
DiCaprio to Oprah calls him superhuman
world leaders like Gorbachev it just
goes on and on and in this particular
episode we talk about a number of topics
we didn't cover in the previous
interview and we also drill into some
new rapid-fire questions so for instance
his best investment he's ever made
quotes he lives by worst advice that he
hears or sees being given out regularly
why he's changed his diet for the first
time since he was about 17 I believe and
we also go into some very specific
exercises there's a portion in the
middle where Tony is effectively on his
own I just let him go
for a good I'd say 30 to 40 minutes and
if you want a very specific exercise
that you can apply in real time because
he walks me through it and I dug in
because I could use it
today specifically I was having a very
rough day called the 90-second roll and
it's a process and he brings up a
personal challenging experience that he
had not long ago in Dallas and then
walks through exactly how he contended
with it and it's from roughly one hour
and five minutes after this introduction
ends to 1:15 so 105 to 115 roughly we
get into a very nice flow and I also
have to recommend that you check out the
brand new documentary out about Tony
Robbins which digs into one of his
events called I am NOT your guru you can
find out on Netflix I saw it before it
came out
found it extremely powerful there's a
good chance you'll find yourself
laughing and crying at different points
and I'm not much of a crier so that
should tell you something so check it
out I'm not your guru on Netflix and
without further ado please enjoy this
follow up conversation with Tony Robbins
Tony welcome back to the show thanks for
having me on Tim good to hear your voice
good to hear your voice too and I've
been thinking about you a lot and I've
gathered questions as follow-ups and
I've taken some from fans and part of
the reason I've been asking myself about
you is because I've been wondering what
would Tony Robbins do in certain
circumstances and finding myself in and
I'll give you a perfect example today
I'm on book deadline right now and I
rolls around to around 3 p.m. and it's
just one of those days where I haven't
felt like my brain has been connected to
the rest of my body and I haven't really
done anything and so I start and I'm on
booked at like a very crunch booked
online and for whatever reason words
just are not really very intelligible on
the page and that led me to want to ask
you I guess a lot of my fans have asked
this you know does Tony have bad days
and if you do find yourself in a
situation like this right where you've
tried the priming for whatever reasons
like the mid afternoon and you're like
wow like I really don't think I've
actually gotten much done today if that
happens what what what do you do what is
the internal monologue or the self talk
I know that trying to think my way
through it's not going to do squat of
course I have those days at those times
I don't days like that a pretty rare
have a day like that but if I feel that
happening and I catch myself up in a few
hours then I I do something radical with
my body because the body will change the
mind the fastest and you're never you
have to find that sense of energy and
passion and intensity back inside
yourself that you know what makes you go
and what I would do if it was my
situation I'd immediately go I either do
something really hot or really cold
those two extremes or go for a run or go
lift you know anything that's going to
pump the blood through me but my first
run
B jump in that freezing ass water that I
always have here buy or jump in a
cryotherapy because I got to tell you
you know you drop your temperature down
to minus 220 every night and you will
you'll have a whole new mental state
that's for sure and so but but really
truly it's getting physical in some
intense dramatic way that shifts the
physiology and that's what's going to
shift your mind and then the creativity
comes and once I've made that shift then
I'd focus on you know coming back to not
the deadline but to my my reasons the
why right I know you do as well just
what what am I doing this for what get
reassociate Eduardo anything maybe read
but I won't write or speak about
something I'm not totally passionate
about so if I'm not feeling it cuz my
body is just thrashed you know I've been
burning the candle at both ends with
just common that's when I've got to do
something physical to shift it to make
that happen but when I do those two
things that usually flows on my bed it
would be for you to remember years ago I
worked with John Denver popped in my
head just now um and he was stuck in
every way couldn't write a damned thing
and he was very very frustrated and I
just took him through three of his
greatest songs they'd ever done and as
he walked through songs that I said I
want you to describe to me the moments
they were coming through you and all
three of his examples he was either
skiing or he gone a run or done
something and then boom you know he was
in this state where he was in the flow
state again and I remember I did that
for him and I start doing it for myself
ever since that time hmm and you trout
do you still travel with a small
trampoline yes I don't travel with it
but I have you know I have it how many
of goodies that go that go and place to
place yeah and how do you use that how
do you typically use I just use it I I
do it because if you know most people
know you have more you know you know
your limp in your body is four times
more limp than there is blood the limp
is the detoxification system of your
body when you're feeling tired or
exhausted or lethargic you know outside
of sleep and hydration and then food you
know it's really making sure that limp
system is moving so I jump on that thing
for 10-12 minutes first thing in the
morning and get a limp moving right
especially if I don't have the cold
nearby if I can't you know if I don't
have a cold plunge or something I'm in
hotel then the
my next piece is to lymph aside for 12
minutes and it's just amazing you know
you get all that lactic acid out of your
body moving and you feel like a
different person
so you mentioned John Denver and of
course I've seen your documentary which
is quite the buzz at the moment and what
we're going to talk a lot more about
that I wanted to ask and a few fans also
asked about this if you if you think
back is there a particular intervention
or that that is particularly or was
particularly difficult and what made it
difficult and how did you handle it oh
my gosh shouldn't so many pretty
difficult ones were there
characteristics that make particular
interventions difficult I remember one
in particularly those in flashes in my
mind but I've I've ever shared this with
you we've talked a few times but I had I
was it was a really big deal was my date
with destiny it was the first time I
brought any reporters in to see this
this is gosh 20 years ago maybe and you
know I always read I think you know I
read people do 10 to 20 pages homework I
read it all and now it takes you know a
couple weeks to read it all I and I
don't remember his name but that
informations in me so I'm ready and I've
done this and Diane Sawyer was coming
with her crew to kind of just do a brief
filming and show all these incredible
CEO types that were changing their lives
and redesigning their destiny in the
middle of this experience I was on day
one this woman kept trying to get my
attention I felt that I you know I don't
reward that right now I'm happy to do it
if it's not for attention that's for
help but this woman it was clear and so
I ignore ignored it and all since she
just exploded and night and started
saying but I can't Liana kid she started
she had her hand like she was stabbing
at people and people were like running
for her going totally berserk and then I
saw who she was I saw the dynamic of
what was going on and instantly I
realized who she was she was a woman who
had 50 she was one of the first people
as multiple personality disorders MPD's
that they call them my the first
diagnosed ones and they first came up
with the title of this and she had been
institutionalized and her story was so
brutal because
she actually her father have been
sexually abusing her for a good portion
of her life and she finally told
somebody and he had her
institutionalized people that I guess
were his friends and they they're the
doctor they're actually sexually abused
her he would drug her and sexually
abused her so you can only imagine going
inside your head where there's pain no
matter what you're out of control we all
have to find a way to survive you have
to find a way to meet our fundamental
needs for certainty for variety for
God's sakes when you're being trapped
for feeling like you have some
significant control over your life for
the feeling of connection or love or
growth or contribution these are human
needs that have to be found in our life
for us to feel like we can function so
if we can't find them good ways we'll
find them in bad ways in her way was to
just change personalities that's one way
to get out of pain if you're being
viciously attacked and you're out of
control
try to become someone else and she kept
doing it and doing it long story short
and um she's screaming doing this people
are people freaking out all of a sudden
she starts talking like a little girl
and like an old man and I mean it looked
like something out of Exorcist
and the middle of all this I'd let her
just go and go and go and I found he
just said to her I said you know I
understand you're in a lot of pain and I
just want you to know that I know who
you are and I know what you've been
through and then I told the room the
story of what she pre was she stood that
with a mouth opening and just gaped open
and I said so I want you to know that I
know you believe you're all these
personalities but I said there's
probably a reason you're here and I said
I think the reason you're here is
because you know changing personalities
was a brilliant solution for you to
survive in those situations and you had
to keep more and more personalities but
you kept doing it so much now you're out
of the institution but you're still
living in pain and I said the problem is
I said you must be here because it's
some level you know oh this isn't
working because no one can love someone
when they don't know who they're gonna
be next and it just grabbed her I found
her internal need and then as I started
working with her she would jump back she
wanted control she would try to do
something and she's I'm gonna pee on his
chair and his you pee on that chair I
said I'll slap you across this room and
you know she wasn't ready for that piece
I can say not gonna do it I'm just using
the shock factor I said I'm not some
stupid psychiatrist you can play these
games with I said I know who the [ __ ]
you are and you know who you are deep
inside and I said all this stuff was
brilliant brilliant adaptation helped
you survive but now it's separating you
from everyone it's causing you to feel
the deepest pain and I said I think it's
brilliant you have so many personalities
children have lots of personnel you say
you know I'm Superman no I'm Batman I'm
Superman and Batman you can do all that
stuff in your kid right so when you're
an adult you say that [ __ ] people want
to walk you up I said see you're
probably great with I said you're
probably great with children and she
looked at me at you cuz I am great with
children and you just watch you going in
and out so anyway you know an hour and a
half process I'm trying to tell you in
two minutes but the bottom line in the
end is the way I've finally kicked her
over the edge
well she goes yeah but I you know she
thought I was one of the first MPD's I
said I know and they're so goddamn
common now our thing because I knew I
knew her biggest need was to be
significant she was defeating all the
psychiatrist she wanted to be the
significant drive need to be met more
than any other drive for her on the
surface what she needed more was love so
I said to her I used the significance
Drive I said yeah it's so common I mean
MPD's are a dime a dozen there's nothing
unique about them at all you just see
your face just drop take it all right
and then I turned around and I said but
you know and the cameras are rolling by
the way so what I'm not telling you is
inside my gut when this first starts him
like are you kidding me
this woman is splitting personalities
and being a freak in the middle of them
filming here they're gonna like this is
who comes the turnaround stunt cars I
got the room full of like CEOs you know
Marc Benioff you know from Salesforce
and you know billionaires and this woman
is like taking away my entire ability to
reach people is what ran through my head
but I let go that just worked on her but
at the end the cameras are still rolling
and I said look they're a dime a dozen
but I said you know I don't think
there's ever been anyone in history
that's ever had 52 personalities or even
two and who integrated in a matter of
two minutes or less on national
television but I said I don't think
you're capable of that it was just the
perfect double bind and she went through
all these conversions in her face and a
long story short she transformed and
then all I did for the next four days
was capture and show her and I said
listen you know anyone can forget things
you certainly we've all had the skill of
forgetting our keys where you go from
place to place the place and then you
find
place you've been looking for the fifth
time through I said forgetting can also
be a skill and then I just helped her
along the way to does let go of all
those personalities and the beauty of it
the reason I think it was powerful was
you know they didn't do that story for a
year because they wanted to see what
happened with her and a year later she
was still clear and when Diane Sawyer
interviewed her psychiatry said it's
just a miracle I can't explain it just a
miracle because you never split again so
it would be a fairly dramatic example
but you know I've gotten a call as you
know and you know President Clinton
little tonight saying they're going to
peach me in the morning what should I do
I've got a chance to work the Princess
Diana dal / clarify what you will really
want to do to make for the biggest
decisions in her life and and British
history I've been I've had a ticket
history of had the chance to be with mr.
Gorbachev and and really hear what end
of the Cold War directly and then sit
down with him and President Bush senior
at that time and meteor on and Mac
Thatcher and and sit in like a fly on
the wall in those conversations there's
there's been some amazing times in this
life that I've been privileged to
witness and be a part of and sometimes
influence I view you as an expert
question asker a crafter of questions as
a way of not manipulating it's not the
right word but changing thought right
changing thought patterns and if you
could ask say all of the past podcast
guests that I have had one question what
would that would that question be and
it's enough first I would never ask one
question you know somebody counted one
time I was in an event and there's this
woman who was suicidal and someone
counted I asked a hundred and
sixty-seven questions before I ever said
anything of that one presence of that
one person right and she was a person
that was completely shut out suicidal
non-responsive so I would never ask one
question but the line of questioning
would depend the person but I'm always
fascinated by is what is the drive that
makes someone the best of who they are
what is the uncovering what is the piece
that triggers that and I usually ask
people a question like you know whose
love did you crave the most growing up
your mother your father I'm sure you
loved them both the most but whose love
did you create the most - what whose
love did you crave the most oh you're
asking me yeah
probably my dad I would say I mean my
yeah I would say so I had a very deep
relationship with my mom and that was I
was I felt close to my dad in a lot of
ways but it was a different relationship
yeah who did you have to be for your
father the other first gut reaction
without even thinking just no filters I
had to be I had to be that's a good
question
and it's pretty rare that I get stumped
on my own podcast but that's good
because this is deep and you're
unconscious because the reason I'm
asking this question and I'll give you a
moment or two to think is what controls
our life is our model of the world so
our model the world as we all has to
have a set of beliefs a set of values a
set of rules how you should be how I
should be how life should be and of
course life doesn't always match that
which is where people get stressed out
and thinking that all their preferences
should be met but if they understand the
driving force of your whole life comes
because when your first born you're wide
open you can be anything a child can do
anything you can you can laugh you can
cry you can scream you could throw stuff
you go the bathroom of your pants try
that when you're 40 see if it works so
the whole thing changes because you
learn from the source of love you crave
the most from both sources love you
learn how you need to be and you learn
it by what they tell you or what they
don't tell you what you hear Utley make
up in your mind based upon what you
witness so just tell me the first gut
response first got responses for my
father I needed to be I have his respect
yeah I have his love I think tempers
love in his respect I mean I the first
thing that comes to mind is maybe no B D
n't is not the right adjective but the
accepting of whatever his instructions
were effectively uh and uh as you know
of me also he said I would never ask one
question well I'm pretty prone to asking
barrage of questions and I felt like
that created a lot of that created a lot
of friction III where I wanted to ask
why a thousand times in a row before I
was that wasn't it and that wasn't
acceptable Oh why'd you accept what he
said yeah I would I would say yeah
frequent sources of conflict interesting
yeah interesting and what else did you
have to be about besides you had to
accept his views so to some extent or
not question it or not ask too many
questions
else did you have to be
what are
let me ask let me flip this around I'm
buying myself some time what are what
how do you dissect let me ask about your
mom let me ask that your mom I say who
did you to be for your mom I didn't I
didn't feel like I needed to be anyone
for my mom she was very my mom my mom is
very good at exposing me to many
different things we didn't have a lot of
money but she would expose us to whether
it was particular books or say going to
the beach and gathering black sand with
magnets whatever it might be she would
expose us to a lot of different stimuli
and then if we became passionate about
something she would to the extent that
she could you know support that and so I
felt like it was very my marching to my
own drummer was perfectly acceptable and
wherever I ended up as long as I was
happy was was was was a perfectly fine
so destiny so to speak so I never felt
like I had to be any anyone in
particular for my mom
I don't think which is also why which is
also why you didn't crave for love you
see that we crave the love that we feel
like we didn't get as much of and it
affects our unconscious so your pathway
of your life of experimentation and
feeling like it's not only something
that is good it's something that could
be great it sounds like it started with
those experiences with your mother your
experiences of anxiety wherever you
would feel them would come from the
experiences with your father because you
couldn't win yeah yeah yeah no I do so
both of those pieces are inside you
today are they not yeah I would say so I
mean certainly yeah how could they not
be right I mean yeah and so what happens
is if we understand where those sources
are we can reclaim certain aspects
that's a little deeper longer
conversation but it's like finding the
pieces with your father finding in a
different experience a different set of
memories even of your father that there
may be deep in your unconscious that
have been pushed away by the times that
and you it's like very often when we
have an experience where we feel
constricted in some way like we're not
able to please the person we love at the
highest level there's a tension that
grabs in our body almost like a muscle
walking up and then what happens after
that trauma or that frustration or
whatever you want to call it that
intensity that happens in our nervous
system is we don't let it go and solve
often times it just stays with us and it
can stay with us 20-30 years later we
don't even know why we're feeling these
feelings and we're trying to attack it
from a million ways often you can
reclaim and heal that by finding the
memory before that a much earlier memory
where perhaps your father was maybe
never was but where you felt an
expression of love that was not tied to
behaving in a certain way where you
could actually feel that remember it and
there's a liberation that occurs and we
find that so I'm interested in knowing
what drives people because it helps you
understand who they are and where it
came from
it helps you understand their strengths
and their weaknesses so you can help
them but I'm also interested in helping
people to heal those pieces that have
come that where a person has adapted so
much they've overused a part of
themselves like their I had to be in my
case it was my mother's love that I
craved I had four fathers so I didn't
really crave them I didn't they weren't
around long enough right well my
mother's love and pleasing her was not
an easy task and she would beat the [ __ ]
out of you if she didn't do it I mean I
love her to death though I'm grateful I
am the man I am because I learned so
much how to adapt and I don't want
people to experience suffering like I
experienced so huge a part of who I am
came from my mom I'm not dissing her in
any way but I had to go back and reclaim
certain aspects of my life to have some
real freedom and myself and knowing
where that came from was very helpful
well just as a side note also I
completely agree and I think that this
is more of just an observation that you
need feel free to respond to but you
don't have to which is I do have those
memories of sort of deep bonding with my
dad at a very young age that didn't
things that weren't sort of predicated
on any type of any of the things that we
just discussed and I've tried very hard
in the last few years also with a lot of
the the work that I've done in the world
of cinema theaters and psychedelics and
so on as a way of facilitating some of
this very early
reintegration and just self-examination
and it's actually I've never been closer
to my dad now ah that's beautiful and
just came back from a trip to Paris with
both my parents and it's so there's been
a lot of growth as a result of looking
at you know trying to ask myself
variants of some of these questions that
you're posing um well you know not just
so people are clear I'm not big focused
on your past but this specific element
of who did you need to be and who did
you not need to be like when you look at
people that you really like a lot if you
have tremendous passion or appreciation
for respect for and variably it's
because you see in them something that's
actually in you but you've decide with
it because the source of love in your
life that you were trying to please or
prove to did not necessarily reinforce
that form of yourself so you dis
identify this is not me I'm the person I
need to be from my mother or my father
or whoever the case may be so it's
really useful from that standpoint so
that you can begin to enrich and expand
your life and it sounds like you've used
psychedelics as a way to kind of go back
there and get me done obviously that way
can also be done in very simple direct
ways through post I kind of hypnotic
patterns that can be done over a course
of an hour or two I do those in many
different events including David esting
let's talk about investments for a
second but in a very broad in a very
broad sense so if you had to think of
the best or most worthwhile investment
you've made and what I mean by that is
investment of money time energy and I'll
give you an example just because it
might clarify the question so Amelia
Boone who's the world's most successful
female obstacle course racer four-time
world champion for her it was her first
$450 which of which was a huge financial
stretch at the time for her first
world's toughest motor competition which
she ended up winning and it took her on
this completely different life
trajectory right yes
does anything come to mind for you
probably the first one was going to a
gym realm seminar I think I've shared
with you I had I was working for this
man
helping him move I was 17 I was in high
school and I was just trying to earn
extra money and my family had talked
about my father talked about this guy
had been such a loser before and then I
had been so successful and so you know
when you're 17 I told the guy said you
know my dad's it used to be such a loser
now you're so successful how come what
did you do you didn't like you didn't
like that response at first but he told
me on to the seminar by this man named
Jim Rohn what's a seminar and this man
gets up and shares with you the best of
what he's learned over you know 20 30
years of his life and an evening and
saves you all those years and I said Wow
any I said you know is this happening
soon he said yeah I told me when I said
can you get me in he said yeah and he
just didn't say any up guys have a will
you you said no it's like why not you
said could you want value it if you
don't invest in it I'd so how much is it
he said $35 for three hours there's a
$35 for three hours I make $40 a week as
a janitor I'm going ice cause it that's
a week's pay he said well then just go
learn on your own experience and waste
ten or twenty or thirty years of your
life and I said it's up to you but he
said I'm not paying for it I'm not even
though I could get yet I'm not going to
you decide and I wrestled for a week
with that decision because it seemed
like such a giant decision but you know
I look back on it now on most important
decisions of my life because that night
stimulated me Jim Rohn became a model of
what was possible to me of what I could
help people out long-term I mean I had
no direction or vision on you know if
such a thing as a seminar an event like
that occurred it all came out of that
initial conversation so damn good $35
even though it seemed like all the money
I'd ever see in the world yeah it's been
you know you know and when I was
interviewing these people by the way for
the money most of the game you never did
50 of the smartest financial people on
the face of the earth right all these
guys are self-made none of them from the
lucky sperm Club and every single one of
them as you dug in with them had
different things asked them about their
best investment and so forth you know
guys like Warren Buffett said his best
investment was going to Dale Carnegie
told me he said you know it's what you
do it's it's investing yourself is the
most important investment you'll ever
make in your life there's no financial
investment that all of our magic because
if needed or skill or ability more
insight or capacity he said that's
what's going to really provide economic
Beata for you because it's those skill
sets that really make that happen so I
found that most people there's different
types of investments where it's got to
start with this your own development
you've done your whole life I'm working
on it I'm working on it and I'm still a
collector of quotes I am sure them in
Evernote and what surprised me is how
many of them are Mis attributed to
people that actually originate with Jim
Rohn it's been amazing I remember I was
I was at a gym not long ago a few weeks
ago and there was a t-shirt that this
gym had made which said don't don't wish
it were easier make yourself better and
I think that actually goes back a number
if people pointed out to Jim Rohn in
some ways you wish you were better
exactly do you have any quotes that you
live your life by or anyone any
particular Maxim's I got my gosh is so
many but I mean I think the core
construct of my life is the decisions it
your decisions not your conditions that
shape your life and so it's in your
moments of decision that your destiny is
shaped so you want to choose really well
alright you know you'd make a different
decision ever I tell people as a think
of a last 10 20 years your life think
it's there been a decision that if you
made a different decision your life
would be completely different today
better worse I don't know but completely
different everybody can relate to it so
I think most of us forget the power of
decision that you know you don't like
your job change it you don't like your
relationship change it you know start by
changing yourself because you just
change people you're gonna you get the
same problems you're carrying with you
right you know you don't like your
income change it and all of us have that
capacity but it really comes down to
making decisions and most people they
don't make enough decisions decision
taking is like a muscle the more you
make them the stronger you get and if
all you make are the easy decisions you
know any idiot can do that the most
successful leaders are the ones that
have to make decisions where they're
likely maybe going to be wrong but they
figure out you know I got to make the
decision quicker so if I'm wrong I can
find out quicker and make a better
decision change to the next thing and
make it go so if they're my life is
about really how can I help people to
change the structure of what creates
decisions and what filters that is our
beliefs our values our rules and our
emotions of it's because that shapes at
all so I'm constantly looking for where
is the tip
point that can change the quality of
this person's life often we've made
decisions 5 10 20 years ago that still
affect us today sometimes those
decisions were made as a child about
life about yourself about what you
believe about men or women or people a
relationship or finance or anything
and if beliefs create and beliefs
destroy either you know there's no such
thing as a belief that doesn't have a
consequence the only question is there's
an uplifting consequence or degrading
consequence and so I'm huge on finding
what those are eliminating the ones that
are keeping people from making the
decisions that move them forward and
making that happen so I love quotes but
it's really more the hunt for excellence
it's the hunt for what's outstanding
it's the hunt just like you it's one
things I love you so much and respect
you so much is I feel like we're
different creatures but we've got some
of the same core stuff in us which is we
want to understand the truth and when I
bring the truth to people and we want to
find that truth in all it's beautiful
forms in different forms so people have
a variety of ways of creating the
quality of life they desire and they
deserve and we're both kind of
experimenters in that area so to me
that's that's what it's about more than
the quotes themselves love quotes love
anything it's inspiring them touched by
them all but in the end information has
got to be converted knowledge has got to
be converted to action or it's worthless
you know it's your own used to say as my
teacher you say you know let your you
know you let your learning lead to
knowledge you become a fool if you
learnt you learning lead to action you
become wealthy his idea of wealthy was
not just money it was really rich
mentally emotionally spiritually and
financially of course and I really have
lived by that what is some of the
looking at the flip side what is some of
the worst advice that you see or hear
being dispensed often in say the
self-improvement world or
self-development world it could be it
could be in any sphere but I'm just
wondering if if any particularly common
yet bad advice comes to mind that you
think is my gosh there's so much for a
big from my been to the start I tell you
I'd say you know financially just
because I finished you four years of
obsession on on that subject you know
I'm doing money match to the game and
getting that out to people and I'm still
so obsessed by it
you know we live in a culture that you
know most people allow financial quote
professionals you know 95% of which in
the marketplace they call them wealth
managers there's 300 names but 95% of
people you're talking about as a broker
and it might be a really nice person but
the advice they're going to give you is
based on what the house has taught them
to sell and the house always wins these
corporations are not bad they just
they're trying to make profit for or
they're you know shareholders that's who
they're focused on first they're not
focused on you so finding a fiduciaries
you know is one of the most important
elements somebody who's legally required
to put your needs ahead of their own so
many people put their money on mutual
funds and you know 96% of all mutual
funds don't even match the market over a
10-year period of time only 4% will
match it or beat it and that 4% is
always changing so you want to get
someone who can give you advice who is
extraordinary I'm actually really
excited that you know I wrote that book
and then I donated all the money and
I've had 100 million people and I'm
feeding another hundred million this
year I'm gonna feed a billion people
over the next nine years which I'm
really excited about my partnership with
feeding America but in doing that and
writing the book I wanted people to not
be screwed over so I spent half a
million dollars quite frankly my own
money and then I donated that just like
the book to create this online site
where people could go and they could put
their numbers in and and they could find
out what they actually were spending is
I think you know 1% in fees is makes up
10 years of income you lose in other
words if you paid 2% when you could have
paid 1 or 3% you know 3% sort of won
you'd be paying 20 years with a future
income out just in fees for the same
stocks the same bonds the same
investments you could have owned for
less people just don't understand this
so I created the site and and I had
people go there and I donated the pieces
and it instantly pull all your accounts
in and showed you what you're really
being charged so people can make better
decisions and then if you wanted a
fiduciary commended six of the best and
largest firms out there and then when I
went through my paper back Tim something
happened that just blew my mind which
was one of the guys on the site
his name is Peter Mallick from creative
planning it's the number one rated
wealth manager for the last three years
to give you an idea and number two
number one for CNBC for the last two
years and Barron's was the first one for
three years
no one's ever done it for three years so
he's brilliant brilliant guy managing
you know at the time about seventeen
billion dollars and he said listen Tony
I want to sit down with you have a
conversation with you because you care
so much about people but there's a
little gray area in the law that some of
the people you do business with are
taking advantage of and he said I think
you're gonna go berserk when you find it
out so when you and Ice you came to LA
from the ubw and I met him right
afterwards same day and I my hotel there
and we sat down and talked to he showed
me how these people that say their
fiduciary is saying I'm here legally
required to take care of you now have
this little component called dual
registration where they're a broker and
they're a fiduciary
so you're going to somebody thinking
that they are legally required they're
going to tell you I'm will your honor to
take care of you and the middle
conversation you could sweat hats and be
a broker and sell you something that is
inferior product that gives them just a
higher Commission that has no value for
you and they can do it so I looked on
about every person the site but one was
doing it I couldn't believe it and it's
just gray area they're getting by was so
I've knocked him off the site and then
on you know I was talking to Peter and I
speeders I said this is a great way to
get rid of your competition and he
laughed he goes no I'm I'm just if the
facts I said no I get it
I said you know what why don't your
number one three years ago and no one's
ever done that and he has this approach
you know you know our billionaire
friends all have family offices where
you know you have seven or eight people
who full-time we're looking at your
mortgages and they're looking at your
counting and your investment you look at
every aspect of your life and they make
it work but you gotta be a billionaire
to have it he created a billionaire
family office type format for
millionaires and I said listen if you'd
be willing do this with people who lose
the hundred thousand 50 thousand you
won't make money on it I know you won't
make money on it but I want to help
everybody they'll do that I've been
enjoying forces with you so we spent
several months together so now so you
know I'm I'm pretty excited about I'm
partners with Peter at creative planning
I'm member the board productors and I'm
also their head director of psychology
for their investment group and I'm now
that's my focus is getting people to the
right kind of person and so I'm
responsible for basically helping
educate the public and of course it's a
partner of the firm if I grow the firm
I'm gonna get more clients it helps my
business
his business together because we're
together now but I could have been with
anybody I picked this guy because he's
just second and on so you got to find
the right person the other side of
decision-making would be I think you
look at health oh my god there are so
many things in the health area that are
so conflicted I think you know I just
you asked me last time about my diet and
I told you I got a really boring diet
fir'd I was I was for what 16 years I
was you know vegetarian and vegan and
then I began eating fish and that was
healing I need and I felt stronger I
needed that and about gosh three months
ago I started I had several challenges
in a row I had the challenge of first
you know four years of pounding my arms
together with such intensity you know
fifty hours in a week on on stage the
nerves and my arms I couldn't sleep on
my side so I slept on my back not a big
deal but then my wife kept saying how do
you stop breathing I'm really worried I
went to a sleep study and founded I
stopped breathing 17 times in 16 minutes
on my back so extreme sleep apnea so
they gave you this this sleep app which
is this like vacuum cleaner to put on
your face and it's extremely sexy you'll
get girls with it for sure and and I'm
just like are you kidding me this is not
supposed to live my life and then in the
middle of this I go snowboarding and I
get a snowboarding accident I trip you
know three of my rotator cuffs I'm good
at handling pain so it wasn't that big a
deal but then the pain starts going down
my arm and I find this incredible this
level of pain that's 99 I mean I can
have a pain but if it was as severe as
anything imagined couldn't sleep
Canadian when the hospital for the MRI
and found out I had spinal stenosis
where the nerves are being pinched and
spine is tightening up and you know they
tell me I can't snowboard again I can't
play squash I can't you know I can't
jump around on stage and be crazy and so
I wasn't going to accept that so long
story short I'm telling you this because
I have a core belief the core belief is
you ask me about quotes it's a belief
life is always happening for us not to
us and it's our job to find out where
the benefit is if we do life is
magnificent so I'm trying to find some
benefit in not sleeping not having pain
having a vacuum cleaner on my face and
just and I and I won't give up on all
these guys are telling me my life is
right and in the midst of all this I'm
also experiencing something insane that
ain't on my wife because I know a
warrior but not only 56 years old and
I've never I'm on stage 50 hours you
know I don't forget a thing I mean it's
like my brain is just it's a strength
and I'm on stage and I'm trying to
figure out all of a sudden what did they
just say and why did I say it there's
like dementia and so that's freaking me
out all this is happening at once while
I've just maybe six months before made
this decision that said I am going to
become a master of joy and happiness
like I never had before as great as I
think my life is I'm gonna end something
as it arrives I'm gonna realize that
there's only two places you can live
beautiful states of being joy happiness
love passion you know decisiveness
creativity oh all those states that when
you're in those emotional states life is
magnificent you treat yourself and
others at the highest level and then
there are suffering states and none of
us who are achievers would probably call
it suffering just like achievers are
never fearful they're just stressed this
is the deeper word for fear but if I
follow your stress it'll take me to your
fear same thing so I never called
suffering if you had said do you have a
you know are you suffer I was suffer are
you kidding I'll suffer have the most
magnificent life I have this incredible
mission I have millions of people that I
meet in love I got four incredible kids
I got the greatest wife in the world I'm
physically fit I got financial freedom
but I did suffer because suffering
really is any emotion that takes you out
of those beautiful steaks so it would be
I'd get frustrated I get stressed I get
concerned I get overwhelmed I get all
kinds of feelings they didn't last very
long but I feel the might say that's
part of life but really what happened
for me is how you talk about better
advice the advice I gave myself the
advice I got I went to India spend some
time with a friend of mine and came out
of it and said the next level for me is
realizing how to experience life at the
highest level every day every moment
finding ecstasy and joy in this moment
with you in the moment with my wife in
the moment when I'm gonna go talk with
someone I mean billionaires are common
someone who is truly happy every moment
of life is not and so my you know you
talk about advice or direction my whole
she became to say look my whole life is
about helping people create an
extraordinary quality of life not a good
one not even a great one just life on
their terms
whatever that is some people that's
three beautiful children some people
that's a garden some people that's
poetry some people have built a
billion-dollar business if there's no
right or wrong but whatever you really
want to get it you got to master two
skills and the one everybody knows is
the science of achievement like we've
got to figure out how to take our
visions and make it real and the people
to do that are the people that everybody
knows the name of and respect and who
have their life the way they want it
seemingly and it is a science in that
achievement
there are rules if you want to know
finance there are rules to finance I
just spent four or five years doing it
you follow those rules you're gonna have
an abundance the money may not be a
billionaire but you're never to bundage
some money you break those rules I don't
care who you are you're gonna have
financial stress same thing with the
body you and I both know we're all
biochemical unique but there's certain
fundamentals if you violate them you're
gonna have low energy and disease if you
align with them you're gonna have high
energy so that's science of achievement
you and I could dig into that forever
but the one I'm passionate about the one
I really want to jump on this this call
with you on because I really want to
spread the word is two things it's this
idea that the other skill you need that
is so boring and our culture does not
reinforce it does not show its true
importance is the art of fulfillment and
it's an art Tim it's not a science
because what's going to light you up you
and our good friends and what lights me
up there's gonna be a lot of things in
common to be some things that are
different there's a woman in your life
she's gonna love certain things and get
a lot of the whole common certain things
she's gonna be excited by the don't
excite you that's just part of life I
was with Steve went and I think you know
Steve's a dear friend of mine from built
most of Las Vegas in Macau and I he
calls me up one day he's perfect US and
he says to me he says where are you in
the world I said I'm in Sun Valley and
we both have some summits Cape homes and
Sun Valley vacation homes there because
I'm in Sun Valley he goes do you know
it's my birthday I said I do know your
birthday Stevens there's gonna call you
because we don't even call me I'm here
come see me should I said I thought that
comes to you he says when you come I
gotta tell you something he said I have
been coveting a painting for 17 years
and he said I just outbid everybody had
sought the bees for it and he said Tony
you got to see it it's
I paid eighty two million dollars for
this picture and I'm like oh my god I've
seen some of his paintings the castles
are amazing is you know he's got he's
got everything you can imagine Rembrandt
and so I said okay I can't wait to see
it so I'm driving to his house I'll
never forget I'm picturing my mind is
like the Mona Lisa it's like a ram
Manion what is this is gonna be
incredible and I walk in this house
he goes look and I look up and it's a
big red square I mean if you know art
it's called a rock carrasco yeah red
square with a little bit of orange in it
right and I look at mrs. Steve you know
I first admired it and I started teasing
my C you know give me 100 bucks in 15
minutes I could do this [ __ ] I'm telling
you you like that ego you know you
understand the guy committed suicide
well if he could be a suicide that
better be his blood on there for 82
million dollars for a nice face
so I teased him about it but the reason
I bring it up is he finds 82 million
dollars of value in that paint and I
respect him because I don't like he
knows each brush stroke and what it
means that what went into it and what
the talent is I don't have that level of
sophistication around that kind of art
so I look at that and I go red square he
looks in it and goes 82 million dollars
of the value that's how humans function
so you and I have to figure out what it
is that really lights us up because
success without fulfill
to me is the ultimate failure in life
the worst advice you can get is going
Eva your goals most people do that and
they go is this all there is what you
have to find out is what's going to
fulfill you and there are no it's not
like a science because it's different
everybody you want to know what's I'm up
here in BC right now I'm looking out at
the forest and you look at this forest
you don't know what God loves the
universe loves it's pretty obvious
nothing is the same it's all diverse
it's pure diversity right so that's
what's real but the principle that makes
you feel like fulfilled
you just got to grow anybody I don't how
much money they have how many Academy
words they have how many people they
like it or like them I don't how much my
doesn't matter what they have it's never
enough if you don't keep growing because
if you don't grow you die if your
business is not growing
don't [ __ ] yourself it's shrinking
if your relationship is not growing it
is shrinking it is dying there is no
in-between in real life of how things
really live and if you grow the reason I
believe growth is the imperative in the
universe not my rules everything
universe grows or dies is because it
gives us something to give and I really
believe that's what we're made for we're
most alive when we don't just do
something for ourselves but we really
feel like our life matters because it
extends beyond ourselves into
contribution so I'll give you a perfect
example I've been sharing this example
all over the world because it's just so
relevant and I also wanted to test how
people responded so during these
premiers of I'm not your guru around the
country I've gone up afterwards for Q&A
and I ask people as well as in my
seminars around the world I'd say how
many of you I said we've lost a national
treasure in the United States two years
ago and I asked this in China Beijing
and Tokyo and Sydney down in Brazil up
in Toronto in America I said his name is
Robin Williams as how many of you in
this room don't region if you liked
Robin Williams raise your hand if you
love Robin woods and 98% of em in
Beijing in Tokyo in Sydney I'm talking
about all over the world ninety two the
people ninety nine percent raise their
hand and I give [ __ ] to the 1% they're
[ __ ] that didn't like it but I see
you [ __ ] I could do that like Robert
Roy that's right
but the truth is these people say they
love him they didn't even know him that
was he a master of achievement science
of achievement you bet I mean everybody
comes to Hollywood big dreams everybody
tells you're full of [ __ ]
this guy did it he won his own TV show
he did it he won the number one show
they all said there's no way and some
people are inch enough to remember Mork
and Mindy and he did it then he wanted
to have the most beautiful family and he
did it and he said he wanted make more
money than he could spend and he
achieved it then he said this is not
enough I want to make movies not just TV
and he did that then he said I want to
win the Academy Award for not being
funny his number one skill and he did it
he said you want to make the whole world
laugh and he did it he want to get the
whole world 11 and he did it and he hung
himself hung himself in his own home
leaving hundreds of millions of people
around the world literally that loved
this man and screw us he left his
children his wife scarred for life and
he was a good man
how do you explain that I'll tell you
explain it the worst advice a person who
never got summer got stuck in his
psychology that achievement was more
important than fulfillment it's the
biggest [ __ ] lie on the planet and if
you get it if you wake up to it you can
actually have a life that is so rich and
so beautiful but the only way you can do
it is you got to understand this brand
inside our heads is a two million year
old brain and this two million year old
brain was not designed to make you happy
was designed to make you survive and
it's ancient old survival software that
is running you a good deal of time
whenever you're suffering that survival
software is there and the reason you're
suffering is you're focused on yourself
you're obsessing on yourself people tell
me I'm not suffering that way if I'm
worried about my kids my kids are not
what they need to be no the reason
they're upset is they feel they failed
their kids it's about them still in fact
I began to uncover we're all suffering
comes from it I found in most simple
little tools I dug in suffering comes
from three thought patterns loss less
never if you are in a situation where
you believe that someone did something
the government your friend your
co-worker your kid whoever and because
they did that you lost love or you lost
an opportunity or you lost respect or
you lost anything the illusion of loss
is the place we suffer and it is
unconsciously even when it's not
conscious because we're obsessing about
ourselves we're having this illusion
that something happened and now life as
we expect it to be is not there and our
expectations are what keeping us from
feeling that happiness on the other hand
the other one is less if you did
something I did something you failed to
do something as my friend I fail to do
something for you and as a result either
of us starts thinking we have less
respect less love less joy less upper
take less something you're going to
suffer you're going to come up with
those emotions that make you crazy and
the worst one is when you start thinking
because you did this or I did this or
you didn't do that I didn't this that
the government or somebody did something
because of that we will never have
something again then people get crazy
inside and the antidote to that
suffering is appreciation it's getting
outside of yourself and finding
something to appreciate because we get
so upset about stuff today that's
nothing
give you a perfect example you know I'm
privileged enough now to have a
intercontinental straight to China 9
stop it's it's unbelievable privilege at
the stage of my life but my whole life
I've thrown commercial and I get on
Qantas airlines to go to Australia 14
hours you know the drill and yeah what I
be is like I got 18 companies now twelve
of them that I actively manage we got
1200 employees on three continents and
seven industries we knew five billion in
sales plus this year combined with all
these people with all that going on I
get on that plane and my brand be like
oh my god I'm gonna be disconnected for
14 hours and I go I create all this
stress what's stressful about sitting or
lying down if you're privileged enough
to be in a first-class seat I mean the
stories we tell ourselves that stress us
out but on this flight it's like you
know you're used to you know
domestically you got access to internet
and you got you can thank God you got
connections to Facebook and Instagram
god forbid that you'd be apart from that
for a few minutes in your emails and I
get on the plane it's like they
announced for the first time we have
Internet
until I swear to god it was like God
entered the body people were cheering
people stood up actually stood up and
clapped and I have to admit I didn't
stand up and clap but I was doing that
inside oh yeah this is so cool and then
what do you think happens 15 minutes
later yeah the Internet the Internet is
it is announced to not be working for
how long I've no idea
14 hours I did never work again and
people like this is [ __ ] I'm not
putting up with this what thousand
wrongly people my point is 15 minutes
earlier it was a miracle
now it's already an expectation you want
to change your life you want to end
suffering stop just focusing on
achievement it's easy to achieve when
you're fulfilled anyway you feel better
actually trade your expectations for
appreciation and your whole life changes
in a moment [ __ ] a whole game so what I
decided to do is to realize if I was
going to take a different level of life
life is too short to suffer you know it
took me to suffer Tim I would call it
suffer and sake a little stressed or
frustrated I just got up my phone nearby
it's all time what do you think the
chances are if you're
right now are you damn what do you think
the chances are with 1200 please across
all these industries multiple continents
what are the chances that someone is
effing up something right now
yeah hundred the chances are yeah its
100% and if I had my phone nearby
there's gonna be a text or an email or a
slack or something to let me know that
and I'm gonna go from this beautiful
state I'm in - what are you kidding me
and that would be my life and I realized
that my happiness was so cheap I give my
happiness over somebody not doing what I
thought they should do and the more
people that you're then responsible to
and for the more likelihood just the law
of averages says it's not going to work
out the way you expect and so I finally
decided I got a number one and this is
my invitation everyone's why I came on
because I'm so passionate about this you
could tell this that probably feels like
a soliloquy right now I apologize my
friend but I just want to plant the seed
with everybody because it is is a
beautiful life and it's blessed the life
that I've had and I've worked my ass off
for it I've been blessed both but out of
all of that nothing compares the last
year and a half for my wife and I both
made this distinction and said there's
only two state you live in beautiful
states or suffering States and life is
too short to suffer so when we start to
suffer we have a 90 second rule feel it
for 90 seconds figure it out let it go
because all these things were so upset
at my preference is that everybody would
do think is a certain way my preference
is I have the internet on the plane we
all have these preferences that we make
life and death it's like this survival
mechanism in our brain is always looking
for what's wrong that's what it does
that's the survival mechanism it's
looking for it's wrong so you can fight
it or fight it but there's no longer a
saber-toothed tiger to avoid so now that
worries about what are people thinking
of me or do I have enough money in a
country where if you live in poverty in
the United States you're actually in the
1% of the world people say they're in
the 99% Arline half the world lives on
two dollars and fifty cents a day 900
bucks a year so I don't anybody be in
poverty anywhere but we live in a world
where most of us are looking for what's
wrong what's wrong is always available
so is what's right and if you don't take
control of your focus everything in your
life will disappear so we have
second rule and if you want later on the
show here we can wait I can do a little
process there buddy for two minutes and
show them how to end some suffering as
it occurs yeah the suffering will show
up again because the mind is always
looking for what's wrong and so it shows
up it's not like it won't show up it's
just you kill it I we saw people kill
the monster while it's a baby don't wait
till it's Godzilla
eating the city I mean whatever little
challenge you got you want to kill it
right away so in the beginning it should
have probably been a for our rule quite
honestly but you know in years ago would
have been a four-month rule of upset and
so forth but we really got it down like
a muscle to 90 seconds and I cannot tell
you the level of magnificence and joy
and happiness you have when you don't
stress out about all the stuff that you
can't control that's just a preference
and you find the beauty and everything
and you use what life is offering you I
mean I've always done this it just it's
like anything else you can't manage
something you don't measure right and I
wasn't measuring this because I just
called these other emotions they weren't
dominant they weren't destroying my life
they were just showing up at times I
called that life no that's not life
that's survival software that's an old
brain and I teach my brain what to do I
don't my brain I don't have an argument
I don't have negotiations in my mind
I've trained my brain through
conditioning you do this and now this
year I've trained it to just let go and
find what is beautiful in each moment
and I'm telling you there is nothing on
earth I've experienced it's brought more
joy I didn't need my wife cuz also when
you're doing that you're in a different
place you're not you can't be present
with someone when you're stressed out
inside and if there's really a problem
it's so much easier to solve when you're
in a beautiful state of being with all
your ability and strength than when
you're in a stressed out state all the
people then getting stressed out makes
me better it's [ __ ] I can tell you
you might look like you're getting
better but you haven't really tried
being in the ultimate beautiful states
and solving something and seeing how
much faster it'll be so I am on a jury
to invite people to make the most
important decision of their life which
is deciding to end suffering deciding to
live in a beautiful state that's my
spiritual vision now my friend his
name's Christian GaN India said you know
what's your spiritual vision that's how
this conversation started he said to
live in a beautiful state all day long
every day that's my entire place because
if I do that
else come to it and I thought someone
asked me the other day eh what would
cause someone to kill men women and
children and you know like you've seen
happen in Paris and what happened in
Nice recently what's happened obviously
in Orlando and San Bernardino and I said
I can't tell you the kind of person who
did but I tell you didn't do it a happy
person didn't go kill all those people a
fulfilled human being a person in a
beautiful state does not plot or try to
harm anybody much just kill anybody a
person a beautiful state is not out
there trying to you know steal from
somebody else and so you know when you
get on an airplane and and the first
thing they say is if we have a problem
and we lose oxygen Maskull dropped it
down and put it on your child first
right no they say put on yourself first
which seems selfish with your child we
all want to take care of a kid first but
the reason is if you don't take care of
yourself you're gonna have nothing for
that child that child is going to die
too
putting yourself in a beautiful state is
putting that living oxygen inside of you
and then you have things to give other
people as long as you're suffering
suffering but gets more suffering so I
always tell people figure out what your
favorite flavor of suffering is you are
you the person gets stressed out all the
time is that anxiety is it worry is it
anger is it pissed off is it you know
trying to please if it what is your
favorite style of suffering and end it
because when you end that there's a
level of freedom but no amount of money
will give you no amount of love will
give you to no amount of accolades no
minute Academy Awards none of that [ __ ]
I get the call from all those multi
billionaire clients and from all those
people may entertain the business who've
got everything and they're miserable and
they bring me in to help them with their
business or whatever it is and I'm the
Trojan horse I give them what they want
but I know what I'm really there for is
also given what they need and to help
them to find that joy in happening so
I've been doing that you know like
managing coaching Paul Tudor Jones on
the top ten financial traders in the
history of the world in a guy who 1987
when the stock market took its biggest
percentage drop ever percentage-wise
still the most he made 200% for his
clients and then he lost money but I'm
coaching him now for 22 years he hasn't
lost money in 22 years so I'm doing my
job but I also making sure that man is
fulfilled and that to me is my real
mission with him even though I'm helping
him on the business side in a way that
he's very pleased with making sure that
his life is fulfilled is my ultimate
ultimate
right so I finished with a little piece
I just think a lot of people say to me
well you know God's not really in my
life I don't know there's a god or an
infinite energy or whatever you want to
call what you think is created you and I
always say to people and you imagine if
you viewer the Creator and you come here
to one of your creations and you say to
this person Joe how do you like what I
created for you and he says jeez God I
mean it's hot as [ __ ] here couldn't you
just kept it at 78° what I do have to
change all these temperatures make it so
tough and then you got these stupid
people I got a deal with all the time
they're always getting in my way and you
know and I don't have to work for a
living and plus you got these little red
ants a tiny Lancer they bite mast they
hurt like how why would you create these
annoying ant if your God do you want to
hang out with this person and if you're
a human you wanna hang out with him and
he your god you go to somebody else you
say how is it going you know the
creation that created via the guy says
hey man god this is so incredible it's
the most beautiful place I could ever
imagine the sky here the water oh my god
there's so many different people that
challenge me and help me to grow and
learn people I can love and oh my god
you've been creating these red ants I
mean these red ants are so tiny I'm a
thousand times their size and they're so
courageous they come even bite me it's
cool what you've created here you know
who do you want to hang with so life
goes I don't got in my life that's
probably because you whine and [ __ ] too
much do you feel God's presence right we
have got to stop the suffering I don't
know many people that don't suffer
regularly they don't call it suffering
but that's what they do and it's
something you can end not like one time
it's like drawing a line in the sand and
say if I want to take the island I'm
going to burn the boats I'm not going
back and then committing yourself to it
and not beating yourself up like you
know I don't say my life oh you're
suffering and you need to change we have
a 90 second rule it doesn't work that
way I'm just like honey I don't know if
you're suffering or not I feel energy in
you right now and I just want you know
I'm here for you anything I can do to
help and we do our own internal work but
if she suffered for whatever period of
time internally I'm there for her but
I'm not gonna make her wrong for it
because what happens is your brain
starts to see how life can really be and
it is more beautiful than most humans
will ever dream of and so most people
try to drink or smoke or do something to
alter their state to get in a beautiful
state
and you can wire yourself to be that way
so this is my little soliloquy thank you
for the pump it out cuz you're such a
gem Tim let me do it but it's just like
if I could get every human being to
truly make the decision keep the word
and keep practicing because it's a daily
practice cuz I still feel if something
shows up and you see it you let it go
but as you do it more and more it's like
like I said it's like a muscle there is
a level of joy as much as you never
dreamed you have I'm telling you there's
a hundredfold out there and I'm inviting
your listeners to consider trying a real
simple ten day challenge to say for 10
days I'm just not gonna suffer I'm an
Indian I'm gonna let it go I'm gonna
realize don't sweat the small stuff it's
all small stuff I'm gonna stop obsessing
about myself I'm gonna focus on what I
can appreciate what's beautiful and just
try and see what happens the end of ten
days you really believe is the most
important thing a wife like I do then
you commit to that decision long term
and maybe surround some of your friends
and family sharing why you've done it so
you got some leverage on yourself and
you keep moving forward and keep
expanding and for people who I'm going
to take you up on what you said a little
bit earlier just in terms of describing
how the 90 second rule works in practice
I think a lot of people listening we
want to take you up on the challenge and
to have the sort of 90 second rule
process in their toolkit as part of that
what what is it what does it look like
could you give us an example of what
that might look like I'll give an
example right how to use it recently um
I was in Dallas I don't know three or
four weeks ago I was doing an Unleashed
power with an event we got about 7500
people there eight thousand people there
and we went to the fire walk was no
different than a fire walk I've ever
done in 35 years we always have you know
quarter of a percent or half of one
percent under one percent of people that
have hot spots or blisters they know
they could get in advance and you know
it's like going you're gonna go do a
marathon you know you could get blisters
and if you do you don't quit you push
through it and it's a Badge of Courage
and you're proud of yourself right and
you know the firewalk that's what it is
it's an experience of someone overcoming
their fear it's something real it's
visceral and you got get yourself to
take action in spite of it and you know
there is some exposure some danger if
you want to call it that but he knows it
and we have medical professionals
on-site and they take care of people
it's aloe vera some blisters they go
away right and not make it like it's no
big deal but it's not a big deal and
this has happened to me five years ago
when San Jose where somebody was driving
by his saw some people coming out called
9-1-1 said there's all these people
burning here and it became the story
overnight that all these people had
burned at this fire walk it went around
the world in the news cycle the 24/7
news cycle where people don't have they
don't send reporters out do you never
you they just copy the same story to the
same thing over and over again they said
people are hospitalized not a single
person was hospitalized
none of was true Fox News it took four
weeks but Arianna Huffington it's been
do our events so she put a reporter on
this who actually went out investigated
went to the hospital thought no one was
hospitalized thought it was all [ __ ]
so they wrote a story and my lawyers
actually worked and got Fox News believe
it or not to do a reversal or they
apologized and said it was incorrect
then few weeks ago I'm in Dallas same
exact thing somebody doesn't know what's
going on calls 911 says you gotta send
ambulances there's hundreds of people
burning nobody was hospitalized five
people want additional attention I
looked at it saw they were fine and
released and they're all in the seminar
the next day but everyone might my email
box my texting everything still people
all the world's I am so sorry about this
what happened to you what happened to
Beeman nothing happened to you man
so you can only imagine now this was not
truly 90 seconds less so I'm telling
this one this one was like at 30 40
minutes because every time I thought it
was done another thing came in but
here's what I did eventually I got
myself back is at this process there's a
scientific stats and of scientific
studies that show that when your mind in
your heart your heart actually has
hormones that affect the way your brain
functions it's not just your brain
affecting your heart they interact when
they're in alignment human beings are
able to resolve internal conflicts often
the conflicts we have are between our
conscious and unconscious mind between
our mind and our heart often as an
example and if I were to put electrodes
on your brain and on your heart you all
know an EEG and EKG we can see that
they're both in your normal state pretty
jagged up and down and they don't look
anything like each other but if all you
do is breathe put your hands on your
heart physically and anyone listening
let's go ahead and do this right now in
a second but I'll first tell you what
we're going to do you put both your
hands on your heart physically and you
feel your heart you put all your focus
in your heart you breathe into your
heart and you feel gratitude for two
minutes we think of three events in your
life you feel grateful for and you step
in and feel it at the end of two minutes
you are in what I call a beautiful state
because I can look at your EEG and EKG
and it's dramatic first they are jagged
they're rounded but what's mind-boggling
and I'm sure you've probably noticed him
they literally sync up they become
identical they look like they're tracing
each other and when that happens it's
not just your mind I always tell people
get in your head you're dead your minds
great for strategy but it'll never make
you enjoy your life it'll never let you
enjoy the taste of an apple because
it'll go is there again according to
come from I mean versus your heart but
you can bring the juice of anything back
to you so what what really I'm trying to
do with everyone in this situation is
I'm trying to show them how to line
these up and it's really easy so if you
want to do it right now and you want to
test that it works let's do this and Tim
you can do this with me if you'd like to
sure link of a situation you might not
have any in your life Tim you're so
crazy in this area and so on top of it
but most of us have situations where
there are all of you listening a place
where you have some unfinished business
yeah that's the story of my life
stunning okay well your story of all our
lives right let's just be a human right
but it's it's a place where there's
something that you should have handled
you haven't handled with a person or
situation it stresses you out and so
what we tend to do is focus on other
stuff because we don't want to have to
deal with that because it's stressful
because this you know that's painful and
so think of something that on a 0 to 10
scale where 10 is totally stressed out
and zero is not at all pick something
that's unfinished business in your
business or personal life with something
or someone and it's at least a seven
eight nine or ten just so you can see
that this really works now by the way
there are hundreds of ways to do this
I'm just gonna give you this one cuz we
can do it in two minutes right so I'm
hoping that Tim do you have one by Jim's
idea together Const okay for you know
tell me the content no one estas to
Kanta alright everyone if you would just
for a moment I don't have any music in
the background which led you to enhance
this normally but let's just do it put
both your hands on your heart and
physically breathe deep into your heart
you're breathing deep in your heart feel
the strength of your heart
feel the power of your heart
feel the beauty of your heart
what are you proud or grateful that your
heart has guided you to do or to give or
to feel or to enjoy and feel the
strength to not breathe into it feel the
blood flow of the oxygen and feel
grateful for your heart first cuz think
about it you didn't have to earn this
heart it was given to you you didn't
have to prove your value or you're worth
you enough to accomplish anything
something loved you enough to give you
the gift of life as long as its heart is
beating you have that gift and you live
it beats a hundred thousand times a day
pumps blood through 60,000 miles of
blood vessels we put them end to end
they go around the earth twice at the
equator that's what's inside every one
of us you want to think about it what a
gift so as you breathe in your heart
feeling your powerful heart
I want you to spare a moment we're going
to think of three but just think first
of one event in your life one experience
one moment that you could feel so
grateful for if you wanted to a magic
moment a sacred moment sexy moment a
beautiful moment a loving moment any
moment really you could feel grateful
for if you wanted to right now and then
step into that memory from it like step
on your body as if you were there see
what you would have solved and as if
you're there or here what you'd hear
back there not breathe the way you were
breathing back then if you filled up
with that sense of gratitude for that
moment how do you smile when you feel so
grateful or so thankful
what's the look in your eyes how do you
breathe let's look in your face when you
feel really really grateful and just
fill it out fill up with gratitude the
reason we use gratitude by the way is
the two motions that mess us up most is
anger and fear and you need can't be
grateful and angry simultaneously it's
the antidote
it can't be fearful and angry
simultaneously so fill up the gratitude
and now think of a second moment you
could feel truly grateful for and again
breathe deep in your heart feel that
power just think of any other moment it
could be from your childhood or adult to
that it could be lastly could be today
it could be 10 years ago any moment that
you could just truly feel like that was
a grace that was magical that was
beautiful that that's magnificent
something that gives you the feeling of
tremendous gratitude if you really
focused on it breathe it feel it enjoy
it fill up with gratitude then finally
think of a third moment you can feel
truly grateful for step in it see it
feel it be there feel the crowd - what
were you so grateful for what are you
grateful for and then maybe throw one
extra one in think of a coincidence you
know we all love when life happens for
us it's not to us we love coincidences
because we didn't do anything something
happened for us you're going to do one
thing and you met somebody that you
developed a partnership with or became a
friend or a lover or the level of your
life or maybe a business opportunity
came from a coincidence or an insight
came from a coincidence that's been so
valuable in your life something you're
grateful for what's the coincidence that
led to something you're so grateful for
and feel the gratitude for that it
wasn't a coincidence or were you guided
hmm now you breathe in your heart you've
been doing this for about two minutes
keep breathing keep feeling it feeling
grateful let's use this state to solve
the problems
so the easy way to do that is to keep
breathing your heart stay out of your
head in your heart and think of that
situation that's unfinished business
that stressed you out in the past but
keep breathing this beautiful state and
ask yourself this question ask yourself
all I need to focus on in that situation
all I need to focus on all I need to
remember is what your heart knows all I
need to focus on all you remember all I
need to do in that situation is what
your heart knows the answer calling you
to focus on all I need to remember
Halling to do is and then your heart
probably knows the answer I've done this
a million times not every one of you but
normal drill might have so people say
raise your hand if you've got that
answer the ninety-eight ninety-nine
percent of people usually do even with a
simple technique and you know what to do
what's next what happened for you Tim uh
yeah no I thought I did get a lot of
clarity and quite frankly even if I
didn't get the clarity on the problem
just the state shift and this is
something of course I've been to unleash
the power within just the and we don't
time to necessarily dig into it right
now but just this the the state story
strategy as opposed to the other way
around I mean it's it's yes it's it's
very easy for me to forget because I'm
so hyper rational and I like to depend
on the brain on the mind for strategy
yes if is is I remember then I'm
paraphrasing here you put it if you're
in a negative state or frazzled state
you only see the problem you only see
the problems you don't see sort of the
space grant between and so yeah it's a
tremendous exercise that's great well
you know it is it's it's taking the
power of your incredible cognitive
capacity but bringing in the infinite
capacity of the heart which changes it
changes the state as you said in you
know in a different state you get
totally different answers and beautiful
states of being we want to cultivate
them so two minutes put your hands on
your heart breathe think of three things
you're really grateful for fully
associate and then think about bothering
you needed to resolve and just go where
all you focus on all and you remember
all you to do is what and you'll get
your answer that's just one technique
but it works so easily and works for
most things
- - this since it reminds me so much of
my stream person experience with you at
the event and of course we've met
outside of the event but I wanted to ask
you a question that's going to segue
into a conversation about the dock
because I actually watched you know I
was very honored to get to see the dock
before it came out publicly and man talk
about and I feel like good films whether
they're fiction or documentaries tend to
do this but there there are a lot of
moments when you don't know whether to
laugh or cry Pitts and emotionally a
very emotionally powerful film uh how is
date with destiny evolved over the last
second certificates up a decade or so
and for the people who don't know what
is David destiny that's good well you
you mentioned earlier unleash the power
within which is my you know four-day
weekend seminar that we do for you know
eight to ten thousand people and I love
if you make any comments because I hope
this some of your listeners will come
join us I know you've had a great time
we can share that but date with destiny
I see about two hundred thousand people
a year in 12 to 15 countries some of the
countries I go to three times like
Australia London and so forth but I only
see 2500 people on date with destiny I
only do one event in the United States
once a year there and do it in December
usually in Florida it's six days long I
do one in Australia also but in the US
only one time six days long 2,500 people
people do 10 20 pages of homework I read
it all and it's an experience designed
to help you to uncover the every what
controls every thought feeling and
emotion of your life every thought
feeling emotion what you do what you
don't do is controlled by your beliefs
your values and your rules and most of
us did not consciously pick most of
those we adapted them to our
environments into the people are on a
please and so our life is a reflection
of us and a lot of conditioning this
allows you to open it up and say I am
now the conditioner what is it that I
truly want most for my life at this
stage where I am today not ten years ago
and what's in the way how do I remove it
and what do I need to replace it with in
my deep in my nervous system not just in
some thought pattern but literally in
the way my nervous
functions and we do this six days and
nights it goes you know 12 13 hours a
day and Joe Bruin jur who's you know an
amazing two-time Academy Award nominated
and two-time Emmy winning two-time
Peabody winning documentarian he's done
some amazing films I'd saw a Metallica
some kind of monster which was a
brilliant film about these guys and
going to a new stage of life and hating
each other and how they going to break
through and intervene he also didn't
want to call Paradise Lost which was
three films that over two decades where
he got three men that were innocent off
death row is that's kind of guy yes but
he's a he's seen the worst side of life
and I met him we have a mutual friend
that created the show billions and which
is an aside if people have seen that
show the woman and that shows the coach
to the you know the billionaire hedge
fund guys I trained her and a lot of
those things are actually things I
really do her sex scenes I did not train
but the other stuff you don't do the
domination in the the Stiletto
domination that wasn't my stilettos or
my stilettos but the rest of its there
yeah right Brian Koppelman yeah you know
Brian that's right so Brian Koppelman
introduces us and this is 2012 and I
just sense here's this beautiful man I
had so much respect for and he wasn't
fulfilled perfect example he's like got
all these Academy Awards he I mean if
you got three people who are dying off
of death row I mean what else need to do
in your life to have valued to feel like
your life was worthwhile but I could
feel he was turning 50 wasn't there so
long story short I invite him date with
destiny he's told me since that he
couldn't understand why he went he said
I'm not a seminar guy I'm not into any
of this stuff I'm sceptical and
pessimistic I see the worst side of life
but something inside of our conversation
intrigued him and I got in there and
within two hours he wanted to run he's
trying to keep it out of the filthy I
said I can't take this energy in this
jumping and his music and people want to
talk to me and they want to ask me
personal questions because I'm just not
made for this he called his wife and
said you know Tony such a nice guy and
he invited me here what's my exit
strategy I can't do six hours more I can
be six minutes for the show and she said
honey you know there's a reason you were
pulled to do this you never would in a
million years you won't even pick a six
day vacation your why don't you stay at
least one more day before you fail and
the next day we did this process where I
have
him everyone reclaim you know I ask
people what the earliest memory is and I
had to reclaim the memory before that
that you don't realize is there and when
you do it releases what was holding him
back and he woke up
you know opened his eyes flooded with
tears he said he hadn't cried in 20
years like that and felt this incredible
relief and he said okay I'm in I'm gonna
play full out and then at the end of it
he saw how cinematic this was these
interventions are just pretty dramatic
you know suicidal ones people that are
so successful and miserable all these
things and so he came and pitch me on it
thinking I was going to say yes and I
said no for two years because I just
didn't want to disrupt the environment I
didn't want to disrupt the people there
because I have cameras but they're long
distance lenses only so you can see the
person's face on a giant screen with
2500 people so you get to be fully
associated but you know somebody didn't
document with a camera in your face a
different game so after two years he
said look what if I came in and if you
think it interferes with their
experience
you ended it's my loss I said if you
want to take that risk that I'm willing
to do it because I just can't let it
disrupt the people and I was also
skeptical how you going to take 6 13 12
14 hour days and put in less than two
hours but that's why he's got the
Academy Awards and he did a phenomenal
job and it's we had a half a million
people join us just on Facebook while on
an update came out after they watched
the film for QA it's just like the
response to it has been greater than
anything we could have imagined and I've
had a number of friends reach out to me
to recommend that I see the doc which of
course I appreciate and I will say also
for those people listening who are don't
have a lot of exposure to Tony or maybe
have misconceptions the most common
thing I've heard from friends who've
seen the doc is I thought Tony was X and
now I think about Tony totally
differently and I think it's very hard
to appreciate some of your unique
abilities and tools without seeing some
of the interventions for instance I
think I think it's it's a it's a very
different visceral and powerful
experience so I certainly recommend it I
mean I've already recommended it and
watched it very early on and just just
love this where can people find the doc
I'm not your guru where's the best place
for people
check it out um it's on Netflix now it's
in 190 countries already translated so
we're pretty thrilled about the exposure
that we've had around the world but I
joined you know I didn't make the film
like so people would understand me more
I want people have a translational
experience and what Joe did so
brilliantly is it's like a concert film
he like drops you he's the fly on the
wall and you actually get to enter that
event and experience what it's really
like and just like a great movie when
you watch the characters you feel what
they feel well you feel these characters
as they're transforming and it has a
transformative effect I was you know I
was just in New York the other day and
there was a woman who stood up after the
premiere and Jesus crying and she just
said I just have to tie I've been
laughing and crying this entire two
hours and she said you know I've stage
three cancer and she said you know I've
just had given up and she said I was
coming here and I thought who the hell
is Tony Robbins what the hell is this
[ __ ] but your friend dragged her
there and she said I'm gonna heal she
cuz I'm in 1 million percent she cuz I I
can't tell you the transformation guys
like I just got back from Traverse City
Michigan Michael Moore calls me up and
he saw the film he used to think you
know what I did was BS it let you know
me personally just not personal develop
anything
I think that's nature it's just all why
it's all bs and he called up and said
this film effed me up because this
changed me this made me a better person
it made me a better filmmaker he's put
this in writing a better filmmaker a
better person he said I think this film
will save lives and silly-- asked us if
we fly up to Traverse City for his film
festival we just did the other day I
mean I probably laughed harder than I
ever have in my life hearing his tell
the story of what this bill did yes
we're really really pleased so it's free
go on Netflix it's free if you don't 190
countries anywhere in the world I know
you're my followers are all over the
world so are yours you can go on Netflix
and if you don't have enough likes you
can join for I think three the first
month or eight bucks but you get
everything for it so we're excited to
have this available for everyone and
just just as a side note because you
mentioned the crying I'm not I'm not
much of a crier never have been but man
and I won't I won't spoil it by giving
too much context but the intervention
with the Brazilian woman that component
completely knocked me on my ass that
there's some really really powerful
moments and transformational moments in
the doc so I recommend everybody check
it out
Tony I want to let you get back to your
day is there anything else that you
would like to share with people any
parting thoughts or anything else that
you might want to add oh actually there
two maybe quick things we could we could
touch on you mentioned your breakfast
but never came back to it oh yeah thank
you reading my mind I want to close that
loop and then also if with your
financial partner if there is a
particular website or service available
people should check out or that is going
to be launching if you want to mention
that sure if you want if you would like
to have a second opinion like someone to
look at your finances for you they'll do
it for free
at creative planning dotnet it's
creative planning dotnet and as I said
they do like a home office for someone
who's not a multi-billionaire I mean
they literally look at every aspect of
it and it's full disclosure so you
understand I'm a member of that team so
if you join I benefit in some way from
an FCC perspective but those are just
want you to be clear about that but I I
could have teamed up with anybody as I
say he's been rated number one three
years in a row by Barron's no one's done
that in history number one wealth
manager so he's phenomenal guy as far as
the other piece what I reason I was
telling the story was twofold and so I
don't give up right so I left off with
you know now I got spinal stenosis and
they tell me I can't do anything I'm
going to a doctor after doctor I find a
guy in Australia who says with a hundred
hours of hyperbaric oxygen at two levels
deep 65 feet below you will see changes
in the spine that people say are
impossible because the new science shows
that you get eight hundred percent more
stem cells released in the body when you
do this and it goes to the parts of the
body need to be healed or that are
inflamed and starts to heal them and he
sent me some MRIs for me to look at
before and afters and it was it looked
like magic so I said okay I'm doing this
I'll fly to Australia I'll see this guy
I got to work on this I got so much
going on my nervous system and he says
to me Tony before you come I want you to
these inflammation tests I can see if
you have any cytokines and he's you know
kind ascribing there so I go your blood
tests and while I'm there man says to me
you want to do a metals test while
you're here and I said well no what
metals like mercury lead I said you know
I had my amalgams out 25 years ago so I
don't think it's a problem yeah why not
let's do it that metals test came back
the doctor called he said I must speak
to you it's an emergency
you wouldn't leave a message I finally
call him and he says mr. Robbins he said
we measure you know mercury on a zero to
five scale if you're three four or five
you're in danger you've got to get it
out of your nervous system he said the
most I've ever measured in a human is
75-year 123 Wow
and I was like dumbfounded and he said
are you losing your memory at times I
was like I didn't even told my wife this
yet right because as I thought I gotta
figure this out and I said yes it's been
at me on stage he said look it up this
is you know a lot of people are
misdiagnosed with dementia when really
what it is mercury poisoning it's just
your short-term memory and he said it'll
come back once you get it out as long as
there's not long-term damage I said I
can't tell you just maybe breathe the
level I can't even tell you and he said
in addition he said how exhausted are
you I said I don't think I've ever felt
some more exhausted in my life I
couldn't figure it out and I'm working
my tail off but I've always worked my
tail off you know he's a Tony it
literally disrupts the inside the the
wood he caught the mitochondria side the
cell again the mitochondria and so
that's the factory of energy in the body
right say year you literally are having
your energy depleted out of your nervous
system they said you can have a cardiac
you know arrest from this experience
especially this level even if you're
then even if your arteries are clean he
said we have to get this out so I've
been on this massive detox and the
reason I'm sharing it though is all this
[ __ ] I went through not being able to
breathe and sleep a torn rotator cuff
spinal stenosis it all seemed like you
know the worst things that could happen
in your life I was practicing beautiful
state and because I was practicing that
had been practicing beforehand this
would have devastated me and look
everything my life seems to be gone and
I'm doing 7 hours a day 6 to 7 hours a
day of oxygen therapy of detoxification
of Myers you know into my veins all the
stuff that you got to do to do this and
still doing my companies being on stage
doing all the crazy things I'm doing but
because I was practicing it I was able
to separate the 99 pain from suffering
so I want people to get this you gonna
pain without suffering the pain was off
the charts hard hard to sleep hard to
move hard to do everything initially but
what was beautiful was I started
realizing the suffering was the story I
had the story of why this happened to me
what I ever get this out of me will I
ever be able to be able you know
squash again get on stage again
snowboard again like all that stuff that
the mind wants to do because it's so
fearful and it's trying to fight or
flight and I just end it end to end to
end it in this College just pain it's
just pain and I'm going to find the
solution this and I kept putting myself
back in that if I had not been
practicing this before it never happened
also if I not had all these pain and
problems I wouldn't have found out I had
all these metals in my body and I'd be
dead within a year or two so the good
news is I'm down to 32 on Anna from 123
and I think in the next 90 days I'll
have the rest of that out of me I'm
doing the oxygen therapy and I'm gonna
do stem-cell therapy and I'm gonna get
myself back where it belongs but I've
been telling the story and sharing with
everybody i knows all my friends to
start with I've had three different
friends with incredibly high mercury led
one guy had rat poison in him he had
stuff he used to work in the dental
field and you probably know dentists
have the highest suicide rate in the
world and part of that has to do with
all the metals that we live in an
environment it's toxic you say where'd
you get all that metal in your body I
told you before all eat was fish the two
fishes I used II always was swordfish
and tuna my favorite
I have salad swordfish and tuna likes
like clockwork and they live 75 years
they consume all the smaller fish and
they have a thousand times more mercury
in them and no one's going to talk about
this because the fishing industry would
be killed by it so I've moved to
land-based proteins in the most part
with clean sources something radically
different than I've ever been in my life
I mean I haven't had anything of that
nature since I was 17 but I want to be
healthy and be alive and the world has
changed so you have to adapt with it so
I really recommend anyone listening get
a medal Steph thanks nothing it's a
little bit of blood and know where you
are because so many people are
misdiagnosed with the variety of
elements and it's it's these metals that
are now so much a part of our
environment and getting into our blood
and pushed into ourselves but you can
get it out and there's a man named dr.
shade by the way you look him up on the
web I think it's one of the most
advanced in this area has a PhD in metal
detoxification he had a mercury problem
himself they come up with some ways that
are less intense than traditional
chelation so I just it's my mission to
build like a sha de yes dr. shade sha ve
he needs expert in this area got it I'll
check it out with Tony Oliva
let you get back to beating the various
drums and the mission that you have and
the many missions that you have set
before you uh it's it's always fun to
talk and I really appreciate the time as
I'm sure everybody listening does I
certainly wish you a speedy recovery
with the mercury God and I do encourage
everybody to check out I'm not your guru
it's it's time very well spent and any
final words Tony before we before we go
just love love love what you do brother
I'm I feel like you're you know we're
aligned we're on the same path here and
I'm such a big fan of your work and I'm
so thrilled so many people get to hear
you and I hope you continue to take care
of yourself and you're a very very long
time brother thank you
I really appreciated this was the
conversation I needed I was having a
tough day and after the heart after the
90 second exercise I feel infinitely
better already so I'm ready to get back
to it and I really appreciate it Tony
for everybody listening as always you
can find show notes links to many of
things if not all the things we
discussed in the show notes at 4-hour
workweek comm forward slash podcast and
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday the vet
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free
exactly the portfolio they put you in
and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it here's why the value of
wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon
sprint and little things that you may or
may not be familiar with like automatic
tax loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of this episode is brought to you
by audible which I've used for years I
love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is perhaps my favorite audio
book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing you will thank me
the graveyard book the second is
vagabonding by Rolf
Potts which had a huge impact on my life
and form the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free 30-day trial
is go to audible.com forward slash tim
TI m and you can choose one of those two
books or you can choose for more great
options than you can possibly imagine
so that could be a book that could be a
magazine that could be a newspaper it
could be a class it's that easy go to
audible.com forward slash Tim that's
audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a
book enjoy
you